Hello, I'm Kyle. I run a fleet of AI
coding agents across three machines
every day, and this is the story of what
broke, starting with me.
This is my fleet, three machines I run
every single day. The MacBook is where I
do my heavy coding and my personal
projects, and it sleeps because, well,
it's a laptop. Then two Linux boxes,
both headless and always on. Linux A
takes the long-running coding tasks.
Linux B runs my short-lived personal
side projects. Two operating systems,
one control plane tying it all together.
And to be clear, this isn't a demo I
spun up for the talk. This is what I
actually use all day, every day.
And here it is live, the whole thing
running on one screen. Real agents, real
work. This is a normal Tuesday for me.
So, let's go back to the beginning
because before any machine broke, I
broke. When I started, it was just me
and a terminal.
A few tmux panes, a few agents, then a
few more. And really fast, I'm sitting
in front of four, five, six live
contexts at the same time. And here's
what nobody warns you about. At that
point, I'm not running agents anymore.
I've become the scheduler, deciding who
does what. I'm the memory, holding what
every one of them is doing, and I'm the
reviewer, checking all of it. One human,
three roles, six contexts. It does not
scale. This
This is the mess that broke me.
I just couldn't hold what six agents
were doing at once. My own attention was
the bottleneck.
So, I asked myself kind of a strange
question. How does a handful of
executives run a company of thousands of
people? They don't hold all of it in
their heads. They separate context. Each
person only ever sees their own slice.
And that was the unlock. What if my
agents weren't a flat pile? What if they
were an organization?
So, that's what I built, a hierarchy,
CEO, VP, manager, worker. And please
hear me on this. These are real entity
types in the system. It is not a cute
metaphor. Each one is its own agent with
its own scoped context and its own
approval boundary. Context flows down.
Each layer only gets the slice it needs.
Results flow back up and I only review
what reaches the very top. So, instead
of holding six contexts in my head, I
hold exactly one.
Next problem, where does an agent's
state actually live? Normally, it lives
inside the model's context window and
that window fills up. So, I moved it
out. Every entity gets its own workspace
on disk. Shared context that everyone
has to honor lives in shared.
Machine-bound state lives under
machines. And inside each workspace, the
mission, the current status, and a
handoff folder, the actual work product
that gets passed along. The state lives
in files. It is not trapped inside one
model.
And this is the single most practical
thing I learned all year. When that
window fills up, the built-in move is to
compact, summarize the history, make
room. I stopped doing it. It's slow. I
can't choose what survives. And whatever
it throws away is just gone. So,
instead, I don't compact, I reset. And
by reset, I mean right inside Claude, I
clear the context completely. And then
it just reads back the handoff and the
history files it wrote for itself and
picks up exactly where it left off. The
context can get wiped, the machine can
even crash, and the work still survives
because it was never only in the model.
But there was still one problem,
alignment. Plans flow down the
hierarchy, but they drift. And I'd only
catch it by walking into each pane by
hand. So, I built a review gateway. Any
layer that wants to act submits its plan
and then it blocks. It waits. Nothing
runs until I approve. And the second I
approve, a hook fires the work off
automatically. One web inbox, one
control point, I never walk into the
work windows anymore.
Here's one full cycle. A plan comes in,
I approve, the work resumes. That's the
whole loop. And honestly, I didn't build
this gateway by hand. An infra team
inside the fleet built it. Agents
building the tools that run the agents.
I think that's kind of the whole point.
So on one machine, all of this works
beautifully. And then it didn't. Then
one machine wasn't enough.
Five things broke. Failure. One, my
agents kept doing the work themselves
instead of dispatching it down to a
worker. The orchestrator is supposed to
delegate. Instead, it just rolls up its
sleeves and does the task itself. Wrong.
So I forced its hand. A CLI harness with
skills that call those CLIs. So
dispatching becomes the only path it can
take.
Failure two, and this one's almost
funny. As I kept throwing more tasks at
my managers, they kept spinning up more
and more worker panes inside a single
window until it was so crowded the panes
were too small to read. Even tmux
capture pane, the thing I used to read a
pane programmatically, couldn't pull
anything meaningful out of them anymore.
I'd literally run out of room to see
what my own fleet was doing.
Failure three, out of memory. Look at
this. That's my activity monitor,
completely buried under cloud code and
MCP processes. Swap almost full.
Basically no free memory left. The
sessions just stacked up until the
machine couldn't breathe.
Failure four, get credentials. The
expectation is clean. Credential A to
workspace A, credential B to workspace
B, one to one. The reality, they
collided, crossed over, bound to the
wrong workspaces. The fix was a clean,
fully separated environment for each
workspace.
And failure five, the one that really
hurt. The MacBook is a laptop, so the
moment it loses power or drops off the
network, every in progress job dies with
it. And one time I'd pushed so many
workers onto it that the whole machine
just gave out. I came back later, opened
the lid, and it had already restarted
itself. Everything in flight just gone.
So, the very first thing I did was build
a boot command, one overlord boot, and
the whole fleet comes straight back up
because all the state was sitting in
files. But a machine that can just
vanish on you like that, that's when I
knew one machine wasn't going to cut it.
Every single one of these pointed at the
same answer. So, I added machines.
Here's the split. The MacBook was
carrying everything, heavy coding and my
personal projects. So, I offloaded it.
Long-running coding tasks went to Linux
A, short-lived personal projects went to
Linux B, both always on. More resources,
the long-running work finally off the
laptop, and still one control plane over
all of it.
But now I've got context on one machine
that I need on another. How do I move
it? Git. I commit the context files and
push. Then I poke the other machine with
tmux send-keys over SSH and tell it to
pull. It pulls, the agent there reads
the files, and picks up exactly where
the first one left off.
Of course, it wasn't that clean. When
two machines point at the same directory
and both change it, you get conflicts.
The same context quietly diverged, so I
separated it. Per-machine directories
for machine-specific state, and the
shared stuff only changes through a pull
request. It's boring, but boring is what
stops the two machines from silently
disagreeing.
Then the gateway came back to bite me. I
now had one on every machine, so I was
checking multiple inboxes again. So, I
collapsed them. Every machine sends its
review requests over SSH into one main
gateway, and that main one lives on an
always-on Linux box because, remember,
the Mac sleeps. Your one point of
control can't be a thing that falls
asleep.
And then, my absolute favorite failure
of the whole project. I was developing
across all of these, bouncing back and
forth, and at one point I went looking
for a feature I'd built, and I genuinely
could not remember which machine I'd
built it on.
And that's when it clicked. I need one
place to root from. So, Discord became
my single router. One bot per machine.
Mac, Linux A, Linux B. My phone is now
the remote control for the entire fleet.
So, where am I now? Honestly, with a
pile of things I have not solved. Four
of them. Consistency across machines,
abstracting away the local only tools
that are still stuck on my Mac, the MCP
servers, the browser, secure credential
handoff between instances, and resource
management. I really want to stop being
the one who decides what runs where.
And when I lined those four up, I
realized these aren't new questions at
all. An agent should just declare what
it needs, not where it runs. Above it
sits the orchestrator, the review gate,
the logical hierarchy. Below it,
compute, secrets, tools. A scheduler
places it, and the machines just
disappear underneath. These are the
exact questions Kubernetes already
answers.
So, that's where I'm headed. I'm not
going to reinvent compute, secrets, and
tools. Kubernetes already nailed those.
I'm stacking them underneath, and
building my orchestration manager on
top. Task orchestration, review flow,
context management. Reuse what exists,
build the new part on tops.
And that's the honest state of it. One
machine, I solved. Across machines,
still rough, still building. If you're
running agents at any kind of scale, I'd
genuinely love to compare notes, because
this is the part nobody has figured out
yet. I'm on LinkedIn and on X. Links are
in the description. Thank you so much.